et pour en parler nous sommes avec
christophe nguyen psychologue du travail
président du cabinet empreinte humaine
bertrand legrand médecins généralistes
vincent jean brun maire de l'haÿ les
roses dans le val de marne président du
groupe libre républicains et
indépendants la région ile-de-france
bonsoir à tous les fronts merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france donc
une bonne heure de conférence de presse
auquel maintenant nous sommes habitués
alors pas de grande annonce sans
surprise le gouvernement se tient pas de
confier au confinement pour le moment
bonne chose ou c'est reculer pour mieux
sauter bertrand legrand et bien je pense
que c'est une excellente chose
on a la chance d'avoir des français qui
sont responsables qui ont compris
maintenant la probable parler des gestes
barrières etc c'est la difficulté qu'on
a si jamais les contacts sociaux sociaux
se multiplient et donc du coup on voit
bien que on arrive à maintenir un peu le
la flambée épidémique et notamment la
flambée du variant donc c'est plutôt bon
signe
après je ne sais pas si c'est à mettre
au crédit du gouvernement ou au crédit
du peuple français qui commencent à
comprendre les choses
ça fait un autre problème vincent
genvrin justement bertrand legrand fait
allusion à la au peuple français qui a
commencé un petit peu à se révolter ici
ou là on en était pas aux manifestations
des autres pays dans le même temps nous
n'étions pas de confiner sa pesée vous
pensé dans ses décisions du gouvernement
en tout cas de celle d'emmanuel mettront
puisqu'il n'avait pas l'air tellement
d'accord avec le premier ministre j'ai
senti qu'il y avait des tensions au plus
haut niveau du gouvernement et même
s'ils ont confectionné on est tous très
heureux que le confinement nous tombe
pas sur la tête
on sent bien qu'il est encore prêt à
dégainer et donc on peut se réjouir
comme l'a dit le précédent intervenants
que les français maîtrisent se mariant
et c'est vrai que je préfère le ton du
premier ministre ce soir à celui d'
emmanuel macron il ya quelques jours
encore parce qu'on était prêté 2 66
millions aux coureurs
nous ne sommes pas des pros coeur comme
simplement des six
moyens qui plaçons notre confiance dans
un gouvernement dont on attend qu'il
gère au mieux cette crise
alors il est clair que cette crise n'est
pas facile à gérer pour autant on est en
droit d'attendre de la transparence que
nous a promis premier ministre ce soir
on est en droit d'attendre du respect de
la vie des concitoyens qu'on n'a pas
traité le procureur et au respect
vis-à-vis des élus locaux et de leur
équipe puisque on a beaucoup entendu
ministre de la santé expliqué que s'il y
avait des cafouillages dans les
campagnes de vaccination c'était un peu
la faute des nerfs quand même et qu'il
fallait qu'il a hâte de te plaindre
donc je suis heureux moi ce soir d'avoir
entendu en premier ministre qui
commençait dans une logique de deux
mains tendues et où il a remercié les
maires il a remercié les français on se
dit que peut-être il commence à l'écouté
un petit peu le peuple et vous avez
raison de le dire un peuple qui en a
assez et à bout de souffle je le vis
tous les jours dans notre commune les
personnes âgées notamment qui me disent
quand arrivent les vaccins parce que
tant qu'on a pas le vaccin peut plus
voir nos familles on peut pas voir le
petit enfant il ça a duré depuis dorment
pas trop long pour moi
on y reviendra justement sur ce vaccin
puisque l'une des annonces
c'était évidemment on ne confirme pas
mais on renforce les mesures notamment
le télétravail que elisabeth bande vote
augmentés veut multiplier je vous
propose d'écouter la ministre notre
objectif c'est que ces quelques 2,5
millions de salariés se mettent ou se
remettent à télétravailler la deuxième
priorité c'est que les salariés qui
télétravaillent aujourd'hui un deux ou
trois jours par semaine
face au moins un jour de télétravail en
plus chaque jour compte s'agissant des
salariés qui télétravaillent à 100% nous
maintenant la possibilité de revenir sur
le lieu de travail un jour par semaine
pour celles et ceux qui en expriment le
besoin notamment s'ils souffrent
d'isolement
alors christophe nguyen c'est un sujet
que vous connaissez parfaitement le
rappelle vous êtes psychologue du
travail
vous avez à l'armée récemment sur la
détresse psychologique
et là eh bien on n'entend qu'eux on veut
l'augmenter ce télétravail on veux le
respecter au maximum quelle est votre
réaction
moi je dirais que quand on écoute
madame bornes parlait du 100%
télétravail je trouve qu'il ya une
avancée qui date on va dire de la fin de
l'année dernière dans par la prise en
compte
finalement des effets délétères en
matière de santé mentale de l'imposition
du 100% télétravail parce que ça pèse
sur la santé mentale dans le temps
notamment parce que ça d'élite les liens
sociaux sacré de l'isolément
et puis on voit qu'il ya une forme
d'appauvrissement aussi une expérience
du travail pour les télétravailleurs
donc dans le temps moi ce que je
pourrais dire c'est que l'enjeu est
effectivement de trouver la juste mesure
le bon équilibre entre des actions des
mesures sanitaires qui peuvent créer de
l' isolement et l'impact psychologique
psychosocial que ça peut avoir et des
mesures d'accompagnement et je trouve
que mettre en place une ligne
téléphonique d'écouté psychologique on
va dire en contrepartie d'une imposition
du 100% télétravail c'est bien on voit
qu'il ya plus de vingt mille appels de
ce que j'ai compris et par jour pour les
télétravailleurs en tant que tel on voit
qu'il ya un vrai besoin une vraie
détresse mais en tant que tel je pense
qu'il faut aller un peu plus loin dans
l'accompagnement psychologique guider +1
les employeurs pour faire de la
prévention et pas uniquement si vous
voulez proposer un service public de
soutien psychologique
bertrand legrand on entendait les
ministres en substance les mots exacts
mais nous dire voilà on pourrait
beaucoup plus traiter les travailler il
ya un certain nombre qui se rendent sur
les lieux de travail alors qu'ils
pourraient en fait rester chez eux pour
travailler
c'est une attitude qu'il faut désormais
éviter les contaminations ce fait ont
beaucoup sur le lieu de travail comme
avait l'air de la firme et jean castex
alors oui les contaminations se font sur
tous les endroits où il y a un
nombre d'interactions sociales
importantes et donc évidemment sur les
lieux de travail
c'est tout à fait logique surtout si
certains le travail confinée après je
suis pas spécialiste du télétravail je
comprends parfaitement ce que ça peut
vouloir dire de s'isoler et la
difficulté psychologique qu'on peut
avoir à s'isoler moi-même quand j'ai dû
faire de la télé médecine s'étaient pas
brillant brillant je veux je peux vous
le garantir
et c'était pas terrible pour le moral
donc je comprends parfaitement qu'il ya
des métiers qui sont difficiles à
exercer en télétravail tout ce qui est
possible que de limitation
d'interactions sociales que ce soit au
travail ou en famille dans la sphère
privée
chaque fois qu'on évite une interaction
sociale on évite une propagation du
virus s'est fait malheureusement comme
ça qu'il faut faire après faut un juste
milieu entre la santé mentale de la
personne qui est pratique et puis et
puis le ce qui peut faire quoi alors pas
d'interaction sociale mais tout de même
des écoles qui restent ouvertes avec un
renforcement des protocoles sanitaires
dans plusieurs écoles maternelles mais
aussi collège
désormais quand il ya un cas de variants
on ferme la classe olivier verront s'est
exprimée justement sur ces écoles avec
un nouveau dispositif qui va être mis en
place après les vacances scolaires je
vous propose d'écouter le ministre de la
santé de manière à renforcer
l'acceptabilité du test qui peut ne pas
être agréable quand on est petit nous
attendons l'avis de la haute autorité de
santé sous dix jours qui nous permettra
d' employer des techniques de
prélèvement nouvelle par prélèvement
salivaire dans des conditions que la
haute autorité de santé devra préciser
sans attendre nous nous équiperons et
nous déploierons c'est technique pour
qu'au retour des vacances scolaires nous
puissions réaliser plusieurs centaines
de milliers de tests par prélèvement
salivaire vincent genvrin une bonne
chose
on imagine que valayer les roses ya
évidemment beaucoup d'administrés qui
viennent vers vous avec cette inquiétude
beaucoup de parents qui ont leurs
enfants à l'école les tests salivaires
c'est la solution justement pour
justement appliquée tester
isolé protéger ils ont attendu
effectivement et que beaucoup
d'impatience parce qu'on voit bien un
test pcr par le nez c'est extrêmement
gênant et pour les enfants ça paraît un
peu inconsolable mois elle simplement
ce qui m'inquiète c'est qu'on entend le
ministre de la santé nous parler d'un
nouveau dispositif de la même manière
qu'il avait annoncé l'arrivée des
vaccins en disant nous allons vacciner
nous allons ouvrir des centres nous nous
nous la question c'est qui est ce nous
moi je serais très curieux de savoir qui
peut pratiquer les tests salivaires
est ce que quand monsieur mise la santé
dit nous est ce qu il compte sur
l'éducation nationale est ce qu il
compte une fois de plus mobilisés à les
municipalités et leurs agents là encore
je pense que comme il s'agit de sauver
des vies nous seront évidemment présents
et nous répondrons à l'appel mais ça
serait fort sympathique d'être
préalablement concertée ce serait fort
aimable de sa part de réunir un
collectif de mères pour réfléchir avec
eux sur les modalités parce que au-delà
de ces tests qui sont une bonne nouvelle
on a également mis en place sans aucune
concertation
un nouveau protocole sanitaire dans
lequel on nous explique que maintenant
on fait tout comme maman garde les
écoles ouvertes les cantines ouverte
mais par contre maintenant il faut une
distanciation de mètres au lieu d'un
mètre c'est mission quasi impossible
et autant vous dire que là aussi c'est
bien beau de passer à la télé pour faire
des annonces encore faut-il que ça suit
plus sur le terrain et pour ça ça passe
par une meilleure concertation avec les
élus qui encore une fois toutes
tendances politiques confondues veulent
réussir la campagne vaccinale veulent
réussir toutes ces mesures barrières et
ses protocoles nouveau on veut être des
partenaires aux pages des adversaires
sentiment de ne pas être accompagné par
ce concept est ce qu'on aura aussi on
simple administrés quand on a des
enfants à l'école on apprend voilà par
la directrice de l'établissement telle
ou telle mesure
mr parfois s'en mêle aussi vous êtes et
grands abandonné de ces mesures on vous
laisse un petit peu vous débrouiller en
tout cas le service après vente il j'ose
dire mais c'est clairement ça c'était à
que le fameux nouveau protocole
sanitaire
on l'a découvert dans la presse il a été
limité dans le texte fin dans le décret
qui est sorti sans être spécialement mis
en avant donc il a fallu aller chercher
l'information elle ne vient même pas
jusqu'à nous nous qu'est-ce qu'on répond
quand effectivement une classe est
fermée parce qu'il ya des quatre co vide
positif est que les parents d'élèves
nous tombe dessus en disant mais qu'est
ce que vous avez prévu comme celui sur
un garde pour mon enfant
ben en fait c'est très compliqué puisque
en réalité il ya une sorte de consignes
de l'éducation nationale qui consiste à
dire maintenant si justement il ya un
cas il faut que tous les autres enfants
restent chez eux sauf que c'est
l'éducation nationale ne gère pas
forcément cette communication
donc ça retombe systématiquement sur la
table des maires qui pour le moment
faute de concertation faute de
communication au faute de dialogue gère
tout de manière un peu artisanal chacun
fait de son mieux avec les moyens qui la
sépare vraiment digne d'un grand pays
comme la france est objectivement on
pourrait attendre autre chose d'un
gouvernement qui prépare cette campagne
vaccinale qui gère maintenant depuis
plus d'un an
cette crise on se dit qu'effectivement
il est temps que le gouvernement
réunissent les moeurs christophe nguyen
c'est peut-être moins bonnes domaine
mais ça reste tout de même le travail
pour vous vous en voyez que vous en
entendez des directeurs d'établissements
même des des professeurs parce que
voulait voir en tant que parents ils ont
l'air parfois fort démunis avec beaucoup
de responsabilités finalement sur les
épaules oui et puis l'épuisement général
qui concerne l'ensemble des sphères de
la société
on voit que il s'accumule dans le temps
et que cette détresse touche toutes les
populations en tant que tel et peut-être
les plus fragilisées au départ mais on
voit bien que les effets on va dire de
la détresse psychologique sur des
troubles mentaux qui commencent à
apparaître sur une plus grande large
frange de population on va dire à des
effets qui sont différées c'est dans le
temps tout ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
tout ce que tout ce qui se prépare et
toutes les décisions qui sont mises en
oeuvres auront un impact psychologique
dans les futurs mois donc on voit
qu'effectivement l'ensemble des
composantes de la société concernée et
ce qui me paraît essentiel en matière de
protection de la santé mentale c'est
d'avoir une vision un petit peu globale
en matière de santé avoir une certaine
forme si d'unité on a vu aussi les
tergiversations qui a pu avoir autour de
l'annnonce du confinement et qui crée de
l'anxiété
si vous voulez anxiété se nourrir de ses
hésitations de ses contradictions de ce
manque d'unité et je pense qu'on s'en
sortira que quand on pourra
effectivement s'appuyer sur de la
solidarité humaine et qui est un vecteur
très important pour la résilience des
personnes alors la lutte contre la
pandémie évidemment ça passe par la
vaccination il en a été beaucoup
question lors de cette conférence de
presse vous propose tout d'abord
d'écouter jean castex qui évoque ça va
faire plaisir aux docteurs le grand que
l'on va faire réagir dans quelques
instants qui évoque la vaccination de
ville en ville plutôt la haute autorité
de santé a autorisé hier l'utilisation
d'un nouveau vaccin en france le vaccin
astrazeneca cela va nous permettre
d'accélérer le rythme de vaccination
grâce à ce nouveau vaccin nous pourrons
atteindre l'objectif de 4 millions de
personnes ayant reçu leur première
injection
d'ici la fin du mois de février et la
vaccination
je vous annonce devrait commencer dès ce
samedi les conditions de conservation de
ce vaccin moins complexe que les deux
premiers nous permettront de confier
ensuite d'ici la fin de ce mois aux
professionnels de santé de ville médecin
généraliste pharmaciens et infirmiers la
suite de cette campagne vaccinale mais
deux informations données par le premier
ministre à l'arrivée du vaccin
astrazeneca qui n'est pas une surprise
la vaccination d'ondés
samedi et puis donc bertrand legrand je
sens que ça va vous faire plaisir la
vaccination qu'on va pouvoir faire en
ville par les médecins que vous êtes on
vous a récupéré par téléphone c'est une
vraie bonne nouvelle cela pour vous oui
bonne nouvelle la vaccination dans les
cabinets de médecine générale
parce qu'on voit bien aujourd'hui quand
on regarde les statistiques c'est par
exemple sûr que j'y de traqueur que la
vaccination a raté sa cible
on avait pour but de vacciner
essentiellement des personnes de plus de
75 ans et des personnes à risque et
force est de constater que la
vaccination dans les vaccinodromes qui
ressemble vraiment à la matinée
kolkhozienne atteindre l'objectif de des
fonctionnaires qui travaillait dans c
est dans ces hôpitaux
donc on a raté l'objectif est très clair
on n'arrive pas à fournir avec saint lô
personnes 75 ans et les personnes de 75
ans et plus n'ont même pas envie d'aller
à l'hôpital pour se faire vacciner donc
clairement si on continue comme ça on va
droit dans le mur
et deuxième chose ça me fait plaisir que
l'on me dit que bientôt je vais avoir
des doses mais comme ça fait un mois
qu'on me dit que je vais avoir des doses
je reste à un petit peu méfiant sur la
caisse et surtout c'est une énorme
déception c'est de savoir que le vaccin
le moinde efficace celui qui a le taux
d'efficacité le plus faible est réservé
aux soignants très franchement je
comprend beaucoup mieux que un certain
nombre de confrères ou de personnes
travaillant dans les hôpitaux se sont
précipités pour aller chercher le vaccin
de pfizer alors même tu avais moins 50
concernant en tout cas les pénuries
vaccination le premier ministre a essayé
d'être rassurant 1 5 million de
vaccinations prévues bientôt des rendez
vous prévus 500000 rendez vous fin
février 7,1 millions de rendez vous qui
se découperont par dont 500000 rendez
vous fin février voilà qui est plus
clair
on essaye de progresser vous y croyez ou
à cette progression vincent jean brun il
faut y croire même si je partage aussi
ce qui a été dit par l'intervenant
précédent à savoir que ça fait des
semaines pour pas dire des mois qu'on
nous dit
dès la semaine prochaine plein de choses
arrive en complément tenez bon tenez bon
les choses arrivent
le problème c'est qu'effectivement on a
un nouveau vaccin qui arrive dans
combien de temps sera-t-il disponible
dans les bacs cynodrome le premier
ministre ne l'a pas dit on n'en sait
rien faudra-t-il ce vaccin là comme le
faiseur aller chercher nous mêmes dans
les hôpitaux pour l'instant aucune
information logistique ne nous est
fourni et puis derrière effectivement
quelle frustration d'apprendre que ce
vaccin ne permettra pas de vacciner les
plus de 65 ans et pendant les pluies
plus de 65 ans ça chante dans un lac
syndrom comme le mien on vaccine à peu
près une cinquantaine de personnes par
jour et on a une liste d'attentes de
plus de 5000 personnes 5000 personnes
sur deux injections vous visualisez il
faut faire dix mille injection pour
vacciner tout le monde
un rythme de 50 injections par jour ce
n'est pas tenable et malheureusement ma
crainte c'est qu'astrazeneca qui est il
faut le dire quand même une bonne
nouvelle
soit une petite bonne nouvelle par
rapport à l'ampleur et et aux enjeux
qu'on doit affronter le gouvernement là
aussi a tenté d'être rassurant puisque
quatre vaccins seront produits en france
peut-être un de quoi augmenter la
production en tout cas de pallier à la
pénurie de vaccins ivr nash et la france
contribuera à produire dès les prochains
mois
quatre vaccins en france le moderna à
partir du mois de mars le bâillon ntech
à partir du mois d'avril
le curve ac si ce vaccin reçoit son
autorisation de mise sur le marché à
partir du mois de mai et le sanofi à
partir du mois de juin ceci le fruit
d'un travail entamé dès juin dernier
2020 par le gouvernement s'agissant des
vaccins moderna by one tech et curve ac
puisque nous avons accompagné et financé
les lignes de production dans trois
sites industriels français qui vont
accueillir ses productions bertrand
legrand de quoi accéder à la promesse
emmanuel macron de se faire tous
vaccinés d'ici la fin de l'été ses
productions sur le sol français ça
devrait accélérer
ah les choses pour espérer d'ici la fin
de l'été ça paraît quand même une
promesse de politiciens parce que on
nous a promis qu on l'actionné que les
personnes de 75 ans et encore une fois
on regarde bien les chiffres on entend
même mon prédécesseur et qui est maire
on si on écoute les politiques on est en
train de vacciner que des gens de 75
mais quand on regarde les chiffres c'est
pas le cas donc non clairement je pose
se fâcher aucune aucun doute sur la
question
il est très clair que nous manquons de
vaccins et il est très clair que nous
n'aurons pas des vaccins parce que nous
n'avons pas passé la commande en bonne
et due forme au bon moment
on le problème il y en a c'est juste
qu'on a presque les commandes trop tard
merci en tout cas tous les trois à
christophe nguyen bertrand legrand
vincent genvrin d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france pour commenter
donc ces annonces en tout cas ce bidon
de jean castex aujourd'hui sur la lutte
contre le cornell virus